>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good morning,
everyone, and thank you all
for coming despite the bad weather.
I'm delighted to see you all here
for this very special program
to celebrate with us the gift by
the Afghan Media Resource Center
to the Library of Congress.
It gives a unique digital
archive of 94,650 photographs,
1,200 hours of videos, 350 hours
of audio recordings on Afghanistan.
That's the largest --
the largest collection
of its kind anywhere in the world.
We're here today to recognize the
work that was done by so many people
in Afghanistan and in Washington,
D.C. I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African and Middle
Eastern Division here at the Library
of Congress, and I will be your
host for the rest of the program.
For the sake of time, I will
introduce each speaker very briefly,
and have put on your seats their
fuller bios, so you have their bios,
so you can have a better
idea of who each person is.
Throughout the presentation we
will have a slideshow of some
of the images from the archive
that illustrate the wide range
of subjects that are covered
by this 30 year-long project.
I will now begin by calling on
the acting Librarian of Congress,
David Mao, would directs the
operations of the Library
of Congress and overseas this
entire library, which is,
as many of you know, the
largest library in the world.
He oversees its various
units to ensure
that the library services the
Congress, the American people,
and the world are provide
effectively.
So, David.
>> David S. Mao: Thank
you very much, Mary-Jane,
and good morning to all of you.
As Mary-Jane mentioned, my name is
David Mao and I have the privilege
of serving as the acting librarian.
I am very, very honored to be able
to welcome all of you to the Library
of Congress here today so that we
can celebrate this very important
project and learn more about the
project, a product of cooperation
between the Afghan Media
Resource Center in Kabul
and various U.S. government
agencies,
including the United
States Department of State
and the Library of Congress.
As you can see on the
slides on either side,
the cooperation has
produced unique photos.
There is also video and audio
digital archives in these archive
on Afghanistan covering the
period from 1987 to 2012.
We now at the Library of
Congress hold the digital copies
of that archive and we will
eventually make it available
to the public through
our reading rooms.
Over the next hour
or so you will hear
from these distinguished
speakers here are the at --
at the table talking about
how this project came about
and really what does this
archive mean to the world.
Just a little bit of
information, we are here in the --
what's known as the
Northeast Pavilion,
or the Government Pavilion
here at the Library of Congress
in the historic Thomas
Jefferson building.
And, as you can see, there are lots
of symbols that represent this room,
the government of the United
States, the government itself
in the medallion on the -- on the
ceiling and the representations
around the wall of the
different regions of our country,
as well as different
executive branch agencies
within the United States,
at least at the time
that this building was created.
So you will see representations of
the treasuring State Department,
Justice and Post Office
Departments, Agriculture
and Interior, War and Navy.
And I think in a way that these
representations symbolize very well
the Afghan Media Resource Center
collection here at the Library
of Congress, because these
themes that are represented
on these walls can also be seen
in these digital representations,
whether it be in the pictures
or in the audio visual
materials in the collection.
They talk about different
regions in the area.
things that happened,
whether it's sharing a meal
together or negotiation,
whether it's building or
destruction, whether it's dying
or planting and enjoying
bountiful harvest.
These are all represented by the
different areas in our country
and in the different symbols of the
departments that we represent here.
So I think it's particularly fitting
that we're in this room to be able
to talk about this collection.
So with that said I'm very glad that
all of you are here today to hear
about this very special gift,
and to hear from those folks
who have been instrumental
in making this all happen.
I know you'll really enjoy
hearing about the archives,
the story about its creation,
and the way it came about.
And I hope it will inspire
you to come and learn more
about the Library of Congress, not
only to use these materials to look
at them, but also to look at them
for research, and also perhaps
to look at more of the materials
here in the collection of Library
of Congress from around the
world that are preserved here
and can be used for all of you.
So with that I want to thank
you again and welcome you
to the Library of Congress
[applause].
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Thank
you, thank you so much.
Thank you.
Well, thank you, thank you, David.
He has an extremely busy schedule
and he has come especially to be
with us today, so we
really appreciate this.
And before I introduce our
speakers, I would like to recognize
and thank some of the people
who made this project possible.
First, I would like to thank
the Afghan Media Resource Center
and its director, Haji Sayed
Daud, who is with us today,
and all the MRC staff who have
produced the original photos
and videos and then
organized, archived,
and stored these materials,
and later worked tirelessly
to produce the metadata in
Pashto, Darti [phonetic], English,
as well as in translation
and in transliteration.
That transliteration is
a complex library system
that transcribes phonetically
various scripts, in this case Darti
and Pashto, into Roman
script, without which,
without this metadata this
collection could not have been
absorbed by the Library of Congress.
Haji Daud is an extraordinary
man, who has dedicated his life
to recording in photos and
videos the history of Afghanistan
in the last three decades.
He has created the single,
most important record
of Afghan contemporary history and
society in existence anywhere today.
He has accomplished this feat
by training Afghan journalists,
whom he has sent to every region
of Afghanistan to film, videotape,
record, and photograph the
lives of ordinary Afghans.
And as the librarian said,
in war and peace, in planting
and harvesting, in
negotiation and in fighting,
in bringing up children, in caring
for the living, and
caring for the dead.
He has risked his life many
times so that this unique record
of Afghanistan's history
is preserved,
and so that the world becomes
aware of what the people
of Afghanistan have been through
in the last three decades.
In my mind he's a hero who has
brought his life's work to us here
at the library so that we
can store and preserve it
and make it available to scholars
and researchers, and to all who want
to know more about Afghanistan.
Having said this, I move on
to the speakers and I would
like to thank the Department
of State, here presented
by U.S. Ambassador Peter Tomsen,
who has been a tireless supporter
of the AMRC project, and has
met on a number of occasions
with the Library of Congress
executives to make the case
for the importance of this archive
and the need to have it included
in the library's collections.
I want to thank Tess Delprete,
who is here representing
the State Department also,
without whose financial support to
the Afghan Media Resource Center,
this project could not have
materialized or have become part
of the Library of Congress's
collections.
I also want to thank Stephen Olsson,
who is sitting here at the table,
for helped with the founding AMRC
1986, and for returning years later,
as you will hear, to take on
the training of the AMRC staff
to digitize this collection
for the Library of Congress.
He did so with Nick Mills [assumed
spelling], who is s with us.
He's a professor of
journalism at Boston University
who has spent 12 hours at Logan
Airport to come and see us,
due to weather issues, and he
trained also Afghan journalists
for AMRC 1986 and then return
to Kabul for this project
for the Library of Congress.
Steve has come all the way from
California to be with us today
and make, as we pointed out,
all the way from Boston.
I want to thank Library
Services, here represented
by the Associate Librarian
for Library Services,
Mark Sweeney [assumed spelling],
and the Director of Collection
and Services, Selina Zinkam
[assumed spelling], who,
unfortunately, could not be with us.
But they supported -- they have
provided support for this project
and have recognized its importance.
My thanks go to my colleague,
Greg Lukow, who is sitting here,
and his staff for the
incredible work they have done
with the video and audio recordings.
Greg will recognize those in the
motion picture and recorded sound
who have worked on this
project later in the program.
Thanks go to [inaudible] from my
division, who has worked closely
with me throughout this project
and has been enormously helpful
in numerous ways, including
being responsible
for reviewing the metadata in Darti,
English, and in transliteration.
Thanks go to [inaudible] and
Fung Tran [assumed spelling],
also at the library, who
reviewed the metadata in Pashto.
To Marzea Rafi [assumed spelling]
and Michael Chiat [assumed spelling]
for their help with
cataloguing issues.
[inaudible] has done
incredible work with the photos.
He's responsible for uploading
these into the library system
and also making available
these photos today.
And thanks to Mike Newbert [assumed
spelling], to whom we went time
and again for advice on IT
procedures regarding the inclusion
of this collection into
the library system.
My role in this project has been
that of bringing people together,
who needed to work together.
I met Haji Daud eight years ago
when he came to the library to see
if there was any way we could
work together to digitize
and preserve his endangered
collection in Kabul.
Endangered because it was
threatened by war, by conflict,
but also by natural elements,
such as dampness, extreme cold,
or extreme heat, insects, etcetera.
Together we worked to get
copyright permissions,
set up an operational budget,
and get the library's
approval for the project.
Within Ambassador Peter Tomsen,
Jim Hoagland [assumed spelling],
and Michael Malinowski
[assumed spelling],
who are all present here today, we
met then with Associate Librarian,
Deanna Markham [assumed spelling],
and explained the importance
of that archive.
She gave me the green light to
pursue this project and agreed
that the library should hold a
digital copy of these materials
if we were able to
make this project work.
For four years we searched
for funding for the project,
and then in a perfect Library
of Congress way, perfect story,
someone from the Department
of State came
to the library seeking a
project for the preservation
of Afghan [inaudible]
that the Office
of Public Diplomacy could fund.
The rest is history.
The U.S. Embassy in Kabul and was
notified, applications were filled,
the grant was given,
and the work began.
The people on this panel will
tell you their part of the story
and I will stop here only
to add that this huge
and very complex project was
completed in record time,
stayed within budge,
which is a feat in itself,
and that those digitized materials
and the metadata are now
safely here at the library.
And now let me introduce the
next speaker, Peter Tomsen.
And Peter has been working with us
ever -- from the very beginning.
And, again, I will
introduce people very briefly.
Ambassador Peter Tomsen's 32 year
diplomatic career focused primarily
on South Asia, China,
and the Soviet Union.
He was a U.S. special envoy to the
Afghan resistance with the title
of ambassador from 1989 to 1993,
and served as U.S.
ambassador to Armenia.
So we've had him here
before on another topic.
He is the author of The Wars of
Afghanistan, Messianic Terrorism,
Tribal Conflicts, and the Failures
of Great Powers, Peter Tomsen.
[ Applause ]
>> Peter Tomsen: Thanks, Mary-Jane,
for the pitch on the book.
Today we celebrate the
integration of the copy
of the huge Afghan Media Resource
Center archive into the Library
of Congress' world-renowned
collection of records and knowledge.
In doing so we pay tribute to acting
Librarian of Congress, David Mao,
who just spoke, and all of the
fabulous Library of Congress staff
who were engaged in this long-term
AMRC digitization project.
Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
as she indicated here,
was our coordinator throughout
the process during this eight year
journey to get to the finish line.
Crossing it would not have
been possible; however,
without the dedication and hard
work of Mary-Jane's colleagues,
whom she has just highlighted.
Director Haji Sayed Daud
and his AMRC office were
already fully operational
when I first arrived in Peshawar,
a special envoy in June 1989.
Before leaving Washington on
my first trip to the region,
I met several hill staffers
who had helped launch AMRC.
In the early 1980's, a
bipartisan group of senators
and congressmen took the
lead in appropriating funds
to get AMRC off the ground.
Notably, Senator Humphrey
[assumed spelling],
Senator Dole [assumed spelling],
Senator Byrd [assumed spelling],
and Congressman Charlie
Wilson [assumed spelling]
and Don Richard [assumed spelling].
But as always in Congress,
the Congressional staff did the
heavy lifting behind the scenes
to make this happen.
We are very fortunate
to have a major player
in that process guiding the AMRC
legislation and appropriations
through Congress with us today.
Mike Pillsbury [assumed spelling],
would you please stand up?
Mike is in the front row here.
And, as I mentioned, a major
player in getting this done.
[ Applause ]
Tom Klein, who was with Mike
on Senator Humphrey's staff
and [inaudible] relations committee,
he was set to fly here this morning
with his wife and join us,
but because of inclement
weather he could not come.
I'd also like to mention other --
two other staffers who stand out on
the hill who helped get AMRC going,
Charlie Schnable [assumed spelling]
and Dick Damato [assumed spelling].
Early on there were many State
Department and USI officials
in Pakistan and in Washington
who played critical roles
in assisting Haji Daud at the AMRC.
Time prevents me from naming all
of them present and not present,
but three stand out for
their vital contributions.
One is with us today, Richard
Hogland [assumed spelling].
Would you please stand up, Dick?
[ Applause ]
I'm sorry, two are with us
today, John Dixon is here, too.
Would you please stand
up, John, please?
[ Applause ]
And Mike Malinowski.
In her remarks Mary-Jane Deeb
gave well-deserved praise
to the State Department's
indispensable role in facilitating
and fund the AMRC digitization
project.
We are happy that Tess
Delprete from State South
and Central Asia Bureau is also
with us today and will be speaking.
The AMRC's coverage of
the Afghan wars began
in 1986 and ended in 2012.
75% of the archive, the
heart of the collection,
focuses on the nine year, blood
soaked, Soviet Afghan war,
during which a million
Afghans perished,
plus the three additional years
it took for the Mujahideen
to overthrow the Soviet
sponsored Najib regime.
The archive contains many
thousands of news items brought back
by AMRC media teams from
inside Afghanistan during the
Soviet occupation.
As David Isby [assumed spelling]
mentioned, had Afghan eyes
on the war and reported it through
the AMRC Afghan Institution,
which was devoted in Peshawar
to tracking the Afghan war.
The news reports -- their news
reports portrayed the desperate
fighting and the valiant
spirit of the Afghan people.
The teams gave their microphones to
Afghans, villages, elders, women,
children, Afghan commanders, and
their Mujahideen inside the country,
allowing them to speak directly
to a worldwide ordinance.
The archive also carries
reports from Pakistan,
from the refugee camps, from various
presenting Mujahideen headquarters,
from diplomats, and foreign
embassies, and consulates
that were watching and
reporting on the Afghan war.
I met with Haji Daud and his AMRC
office on every visit to Peshawar.
It was completely an
Afghan operation.
An AK-47 leaned on his
bed in a corner room,
attesting to the dangers
that he faced every day.
No foreigners were
present, only Afghans.
They were all young,
dedicated and well-trained.
When not editing film or processing
photos, they were going back
and forth into Afghanistan,
operating out of Mujahideen
areas sometimes for weeks,
sometimes for months,
bringing windows on the war
in every Afghan region to
audiences around the globe.
Let's now pause for a
moment, if you will,
to ponder why the AMRC
archive built by Haji Daud
and his AMRC journalists
is so unique,
and indeed so historically
important.
In large part the answer
lies in the relative paucity
of reliable reportage the war
following the 1979 Soviet invasion.
In the U.S., and internationally,
it is easy to access the prolific
media coverage of World War II,
the Korean War, the Vietnam War,
not to mention the post-9/11
wars in Iraq and Afghanistan.
But there is a huge gap, almost I
would say a blank space regarding
on the ground coverage
of the Soviet Afghan war.
Some of you in this room made
it past Pakistani border guards
and Soviet outposts to
report on the fighting,
but not many Western journals and
cameramen were able to venture
for long periods inside
most of Afghanistan.
Soviet propaganda, of course, was
bountiful throughout this period,
but it delivered a false
and cynical narrative
of the true situation
inside the country.
The vast, usually originally
sourced AMRC archive now housed
in the Library of Congress will
fill this nearly blank space.
For the decades to come it will
be the most authentic source
for anyone, anywhere,
seeking accurate information
on the Soviet Afghan war to include
historians, scholars, authors,
policymakers inside and outside
governments, members of the media,
the military, diplomats,
and politicians.
And the archive's importance does
not end, as Haji Daud will tell you,
with the Soviet [inaudible]
Najib regime's overthrow in 1992.
For in the global and
strategic context,
Afghanistan had been a major
battlefield of the Cold War,
one that had spread the collapse
of the last political totalitarian
empire of the 20th century.
But then, sadly and immediately,
Afghanistan became
a major battlefield
against the first religious
totalitarian movement
of the 21st century, and that
conflict tragically continues today
without letup.
In closing, let us again
hail Haji Sayed Daud,
for his many achievements as a
director of AMRC, for his courage,
and for his persistence
in overcoming the most
daunting obstacles in his path,
and also the Library of
Congress for accepting
and digitizing the entire AMRC
archive and making it available
in three languages to all.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And now we are
going to hear from the man himself,
Haji Sayed Daud, the director of
the Afghan Media Resource Center,
who will give us a brief
overview of 30 years of his work.
[ Applause ]
>> Haji Sayed Daud:
Good morning, everyone.
It is my great pleasure to be among
my family, friends, and colleagues.
I would like to thank the staff
at the Liberty of Congress
for putting together the ceremony.
If I telling you that story
I think the last 30 years,
we have just three or five
minutes, we don't have enough time.
Just [inaudible] the Afghan
Media Resource Center set
up by Afghan professional,
by funding of Boston
University in 1986.
The person who came first, that was
Nike Mills and his three colleagues.
Nick Mills and [inaudible]
two colleagues,
they started training program
for the Afghan refugees.
They started training in
video, photo, print reporting.
When they finished that training
for the first session they
started second session of training.
In that time just I was
[inaudible] proposal for production.
When these young Afghan refugees
[inaudible] from this training,
what will be the future
for these people?
I think when we finished the
second session of the training many
of my colleagues I am glad they
are here, John Dixon, Dick Hogland,
and Bret Hanson [assumed spelling].
We worked together in that time,
with Stephen and Nick [inaudible]
with all these political leaders.
And I met these guys, all the
political leaders, and I asked them,
look, these are our [inaudible]
and brothers, they got training
and they equipped by
Boston University.
We want to coverage
Afghanistan situation,
which that was very
tough in that time.
Because all the foreign journalists
they are sitting in Peshawar,
and they are making report
from inside of Afghanistan.
Few of these film producer, I
think include Stephen Olsson,
they visit Peshawar camps and
they did their documentaries.
I think one of these people,
which is very, very --
they did a great job in that time.
His name is [inaudible] and
his crew, which is [inaudible]
and also the guy, his name
is Andy [assumed spelling].
They are three British-based
film producers.
They -- for the first time they
travel to north Afghanistan,
and they also shoot film
from [inaudible] and for all
who are the [inaudible] provinces.
All these, and other documentaries
in 1980's, in the early '80s,
just producing from Peshawar
and [inaudible] camps,
some of them they went
to like [inaudible],
nobody coverage from [inaudible].
When we did finish that training and
we spoke with the political leaders
and I ask them for support letters,
and also they must give
us some representative,
and all these parties they
gave us support letter,
we support this mission,
and they introduced us
as they are representative, which is
last former President, Hamid Karzai,
was representative
of Mujahideen party.
They call them Afghanistan
National Liberation Front.
[inaudible] for all these
Afghans who are intellectual,
who belong to the parties,
we started production.
In three months we
started distribution.
I think Stephen did a trip to London
and he talked with [inaudible]
and CNN, because nobody knows
about Afghan Media Resource Center.
That was the first time
these people thinking, oh,
that Afghan come demand
[inaudible] photographer,
they are doing their own coverage.
And also he did talk
with the [inaudible],
Black Star [assumed spelling],
and [inaudible] agencies.
We started our distribution.
In that time I want -- I
[inaudible] want to mention the name
of the people, just that
it's very, very important
because in the beginning
we did a proposal.
This is Independent Media Center.
In that time [inaudible] and
Prime Minister [inaudible],
he tried to take over this project
to one of the political party.
I think our friends,
some of them they are --
he is here and I don't
want to mention his name
because I don't have permission.
And just [inaudible] and he pass
away in [inaudible] and he stand up,
support AMRC and talk
with [inaudible] Humphrey,
and [inaudible] Humphrey
directly called [inaudible].
And later [inaudible] agree
the AMRC will be independent.
And second time that was, I
think, [inaudible] is here
and also [inaudible] was the
Ambassador of United State
and Islam, but we are very
good friends in that time.
And Peter Tomsen was
also special [inaudible].
And [inaudible] he tried
to transfer AMRC to AIG,
they called him Afghanistan
[inaudible].
And these guys asking them
we couldn't support AMRC
when you guys want to
transfer that to AIG,
and this is independent center.
That was the second time.
And just we did a coverage from
2000 -- sorry, from 1986 to 2012.
That coverage is included Soviet
invasion, internal fighting
of Mujahideen, Taliban
period, and also 9/11 post-war
of Afghanistan what going
on there until today.
The thing is this material belong
to all 34 province of Afghanistan.
And that contain more than 30
subjects, like agriculture,
education, fighting,
[inaudible], election,
human rights, women rights.
We did collect all these
material, like 3,000 hours videos,
150,000 photograph and slides,
and three -- 2,000 audio.
When I make [inaudible] for the
first time that was January 9, 2008,
and I think John Dixon was
also with me in that meeting.
I ask her, what about this material,
because that's very difficult
to keep the quality of the
videos and audios and photos.
She told me that's fine
and you can approve it.
This is your material.
All this belong to you, because
we are wondering someone else
or the Afghan government [inaudible]
mentioning this material belong
to Afghanistan.
Finally, I got back to Kabul.
I call Mr. Karzai offices,
Hamid Karzai
and I set up appointment with him.
And I asked him, look,
President Karzai,
if you need this archive I want
to donate it to the government,
because this is the
property of Afghan nation.
This not my own property.
I did that for the Afghan
nation, Afghan people.
Just he was quiet for one minute,
enough that one minute he gave me
answer, Haji Daud, you can keep it,
because if you donate it to
us my staff will be selling
that material to the private TVs.
I asked them, please, I
need a letter from you.
You can write a letter [inaudible],
his own property belongs
to Haji Daud.
And he asked the [inaudible]
information minister
and he did write that letter to me
and I collected all the
registration, titles,
and letter of culture
information from the minister
and I brought them
to Mary-Jane Deeb.
It take one year.
Mary-Jane Deeb also
follow up that procedure.
Later we get to the U.S.
Embassy in Kabul for the fund,
which is Mary-Jane Deeb [inaudible].
She spoke here in Washington, D.C.
I spoke there in Kabul Embassy,
which the guy, [inaudible], he's
working for [inaudible] of America.
He was also in that
meeting because he work
for the Public Affair
Offices there in Kabul.
We did set up proposal in 2011.
I recommended to my colleagues,
who are voluntarily working
with the AMRC, Nick
Mills and Stephen Olsson.
I ask Mary-Jane Deeb, I can
recommend to you these two guys.
They can come to Washington, D.C.,
and they can get the training
and they can just return
back to Afghanistan.
I -- these two guys got the
training and they got back to Kabul
and they train our staff.
You can maybe see in
the videos and photos.
And we started with
our Afghan colleagues
and we selected 1,200
hours video from 3,000,
and also we selected 96 --
94,652 photograph and slides,
and also we selected
357 hours audio,
which is that selective material
like [inaudible] metadata
in three language,
Pashto, Darti, and English.
And finally I can tell you it's
not the work of one person.
If I tell you the reality,
120 Afghan professionals
for the production with the AMRC.
And 30 Afghans they're
working with the digitization,
because it take also seven years.
We started 2008 and we
finish it by December 2015.
This is not the journey
of one person,
of not work of the one person,
150 Afghans was involved with it.
And also there is more than
10 foreigners, professionals,
including Stephen Olsson and
Nick Mills from 1986 to 2015.
They stay with us and they
give us advice all the time.
We exchange e-mails and
telephone conversation.
And now I'm happy this material will
be gifting one copy, one digital --
digitized copy to the
library, the student scholar,
and also journalists
can use it here.
Maybe some of our Afghan
colleagues they must be thinking,
what about Afghanistan.
Because you are Afghan, you grow
up there, you went to university,
you working for national
[inaudible] TV
and you put this material
here in the library.
What about Afghanistan?
I already did two digitized
copy, same copy,
one copy for Kabul
University Library,
one copy for the National
[inaudible] TV.
The problem is right now in
Afghanistan there is no copyright.
I hope [inaudible] fix their
problem and I can donate it
to the Afghan students and
scholar and researchers.
And thanks again from Mary-Jane
Deeb, who did a lot of work with us
and she was organized all the
things and thanks for her stuff
and [inaudible] Gregory Lukow.
He's chief of [inaudible]
division and he did a lot
with us in video, audios.
I appreciate his work and
also his staff's work.
And thank you -- thanks
from the State Department,
they're funding this project.
And I think in the beginning we
estimated maybe $1 million project,
or 600,000 project, and
Mary-Jane Deeb knows
that we did that with less money.
And we calculated [inaudible] I'm
glad they use taxpayer money is
not wasted.
And because in these days
everybody talking about Afghanistan,
there is corruption, the
people is involved with that.
And we calculated cent
by cent, dollar by dollar
with the U.S. Embassy
people in Kabul.
I think the guy who
did with me that is --
his name is Michael
Huff [assumed spelling].
He calculated all this
audit reports.
And also thanks for all of
our friends and colleagues,
the journalists in this history
given, and thank you again
and thank you for coming
on this rainy day.
Thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]
And as Haji Daud has pointed
out, we have one copy and copies
of those wonderful materials
remain in Afghanistan,
so the patrimony is
preserved both here and there.
And so those materials will become
available for the use of leaders
and researchers very soon.
And now to the next
speaker, Stephen Olsson.
Stephen was there at
the very beginning,
as Haji Daud has pointed out.
He is the President of Culture
and Education Media since 1983.
He has produced and
directed documentary films,
television series, and feature
news reports throughout the world
for U.S. and European broadcasters,
and has won numerous national
and international awards.
And you have the forms, you can
read more about him and his work,
and he's going to share
with us a few minutes
of his own experience with AMRC, so.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Olsson:
Thank you, Mary-Jane,
[speaking foreign language].
Greetings, everyone.
It's truly a joy to be here.
I don't know if we
ever foresaw this day.
But it's such a pleasure
to celebrate the fruition
of all this work that
Haji has just described,
and to be a small part of that.
I did have the great pleasure
to travel through Afghanistan
in the 1970's as an
undergraduate anthropology student.
I was able to visit various parts
of the country, a fascinating
and strikingly beautiful country and
culture that made a profound effect
on me, and I think that's what kept
bringing me back top Afghanistan.
In those times many Afghans called
these times the golden years.
And they still burn brightly
in my memory as a time
of great hospitality, great
friendship, adventure,
and exchange with so many
of the warm generous people
that I met in Afghanistan.
And also committed Westerners
even at that time, such as Louis
and Nancy Dupres [assumed spelling],
who sent me to their research
villages in [inaudible],
parts of Afghanistan that
were so precious prior
to the Soviet invasion, and I really
felt so blessed to have been there
and met wonderful people.
This so called golden year period
ended, of course, on December 24,
'79, with the Soviet invasion.
The Soviet Afghan war had begun
with a brutal foreign
occupying military force.
And as a lover of Afghanistan and
now a filmmaker, I returned in '83
to make a documentary film
about the early successes
of the Afghan resistance.
The film was called Afghanistan,
The Fight for a Way of Life.
I'm mentioning this because as I
left Afghanistan I gave my film
camera and many rolls
of film footage
to my Afghan photographer friends,
because it was clear to me,
and I think many other
filmmakers who were there,
or the few other filmmakers that
were there, that there were parts
of Afghanistan that we just
could not visit any longer.
It was too risky.
We would be spotted.
I died my hair dark brown
and a dark brown beard.
I did that three or four trips.
It just got increasingly dangerous.
And it was obvious that Afghans were
needed to get close to the story,
what was really happening.
Back in the U.S. I happened to
meet Tom Guttier [assumed spelling]
and [inaudible] from the
University of Nebraska,
Center for Afghanistan Studies.
They liked my PBS documentary
and subsequently hired me
to draft the media
component for their proposal
to establish an Afghan
Media Resource Center.
Nebraska had the academics.
They had the real Afghan
area experts,
but no communications people.
And as you know, Boston University
had all the communications people,
but no real Afghan expertise.
I consulted in Omaha for a week.
I went back to Pakistan to show my
film to the Afghans who appeared
in it, and I happened to see in the
Muslim English language newspaper
in Peshawar, a team of trainers
had arrived from Boston University
to establish a training project
for Afghans in university town,
which was so bizarre because the
University of Nebraska never told me
who finally got that grant.
Here I was back in Peshawar and
I hope in a rickshaw and got
to Canal Bank [phonetic]
Road where I meet Nick Mills.
And this amazing feeling,
so happy to be there,
so happy the other trainers and
everything, so happy it was going on
but somehow feeling --
after being so involved
in the continent being oblivious
to how this all happened.
Anyway, Nick and I hit it
off and Nick recommended
to the Boston University
Dean, [inaudible],
who a few days later sent me a
business class ticket to come
to Boston immediately for an
interview, where after a few hours
of questioning I was hired to
be the U.S. project director,
with a mandate to find an Afghan
director and an Afghan staff.
So Nick had set up meetings
with Mujahideen parties,
as Haji mentioned.
Haji came to visit the AMRC with
the [inaudible] Islami group.
Haji had a journalism degree.
He was a television producer.
He worked both with news and
with cultural programming,
which I thought was so important.
We got along very well
professionally and otherwise.
And in this sea of war,
refugees, spies, and vast amounts
of well-meaning money, of all
the Afghans that I had met,
Haji Daud struck me as an extremely
honest and trustworthy man.
So with Nick and my
recommendation, Boston hired --
officially hired Haji Daud
to be the AMRC director.
He is a politically
astute media professional
who had wonderful contacts with
all the Afghan resistance parties,
as well as with exiled
Afghan journalists.
When I say all of the
resistance parties,
I must say he also connected
with [inaudible] groups
from different parts of Afghanistan.
Haji Daud was talking [inaudible]
commanders, journalists and,
as you've come to learn many of you
through the big [inaudible] divide,
this was in Afghanistan
very important.
We started our first
week training session,
and then started dispatching crews
to different parts of the country
with video and photo cameras, story
ideas, and even specific shot lists.
We had 25 new video
camera packages to assign,
50 35 millimeter photo cameras,
audio cassette recorders,
and lots of work to do.
Haji, Nick, and I tried
to spend time
with the cameramen before they left,
reminding them that in addition
to generating the combat
related footage and stories,
which was their primarily
assignment,
to also document Afghan cultural
life, wedding, Nowruz celebrations,
New Year celebrations, children,
families, and other social events.
It should be mentioned that this
war was called the Hidden War
because for years virtually no
Western journalists were willing
to take the risks to go
deeply into Afghanistan.
As Haji mentioned, there
were no reports coming
from central Afghanistan or from
the far west or the far north,
where it would require often nine,
10 days of travel to
reach the location.
So for the next year and a
half under Haji's direction,
AMRC dispatched over 100 two
to three men crews to all parts
of Afghanistan, mostly to
places with no electricity,
no battery chargers, no
phone service, and no roads.
Our AMRC news teams sometimes
delayed for weeks due to bad weather
or being detained by local warlords,
who would eventually return
to [inaudible] and sit
down with our editors
to create our weekly AMRC news
reports, which we would then rush
to send via DHL to syndication
services in London, like Viz News,
which is the parent
company of [inaudible].
These services would check
our stories for accuracy
and professionalism and then
feed weekly AMRC stories
to over 245 broadcasters in
over 100 countries worldwide.
Meanwhile, AMRC photos
were being distributed
through Sigma, Black Star, and AFP.
The AMRC was starting to
achieve some of its goals.
Then on December 31,
'87, Boston University
and Dean [inaudible] were
suddenly phased out of the project.
As Boston left I agreed to stay
on as the senior media advisor,
now to an AMRC that was finally
independent, run totally by Afghans,
with no American bosses
or supervision.
Then after setting up the
international distribution,
I was able to do as the British
say, make myself redundant
and leave the project
totally to Haji and his staff,
which was a shared dream of Nick
Mills and mine from the beginning,
that we should phase ourselves
out of this as soon as possible.
Peter Tomsen, Ambassador Tomsen
did a wonderful job describing the
significance of the project.
What I would only like to add is
I think the AMRC was finally able
to open a window on this hidden
war and generate news reports
and documentation from 25 of
Afghanistan's then 29 provinces,
reports that made an
impact on viewers
and governments throughout
the world.
In the process, more than
20 of our journalists
and cameramen were injured,
and two of our cameramen,
[inaudible] were killed while
on assignment for the AMRC.
Nick Mills says the best thing he
did for the AMRC was to find me,
and I say the best thing
I did for the AMRC was
to hire Haji Daud as
project director.
[ Applause ]
Aside from the management
and professional results,
there was no theft, fraud,
or embezzlement practices
which you've heard have
achieved epidemic proportions
in this new U.S. funded Afghanistan.
Haji has run an honorable, focused,
tight ship for almost 30 years.
His head of -- his directors of all
departments have stayed with him
for over -- for almost 30 years,
reappeared for this archive project,
admirable to see such long-term
faith in real professional Afghans.
In 2002 Haji and I worked
together first drafting a proposal
for funding an archive at
Williams College, and then again
after September 11 with other
friends, many of whom are
in the room, on a new proposal and
budget to the U.S. Embassy in Kabul.
The AMRC archives would
be transferred
onto the highest quality,
uncompressed digital files
with accompanying metadata to
provide contextual information,
accessibility, and
relevance over time,
over decades, and even
over centuries.
I remember speaking with Greg
Lukow and James Snyder at --
here at the LOC about this thing
we call time, and especially
as a filmmaker I was amazed
to hear that these guys think
of preservation in terms of
300 to 500 years or more.
So I think today is a
fine day for Haji Daud,
for the AMRC, and for Afghanistan.
I would like to finish by
showing you a short video
that I put together very quickly
about the digital capturing
and the corresponding metadata logs
that were designed to make this body
of material accessible, to
Africans and non-Afghans alike.
This is just three minutes long,
but hopefully will give you a sense
of the people and the project.
[ Music ]
The Afghan Media Resource Center was
founded Peshawar, Pakistan in 19876.
The goal was to train
Afghan journalists
to document the Afghan Soviet
war throughout Afghanistan's
29 provinces.
Instructors from Boston University
trained over 125 Afghan journalists,
photographers, and video cameramen.
Each of the Afghan resistance
parties nominated candidates
for training.
Haji Sayed Daud was selected to
be the AMRC project director.
Video reports produced by the AMRC
were soon broadcast by the BBC, CNN,
WTN, and other news
syndication outlets in more
than 120 countries around the world.
AMRC photographs were distributed
internationally by Sigma,
Photo Agency, and [inaudible] Press.
Over seven years the AMRC
accumulated an archive
of approximately 3,000 hours
of videotape, 100,000 negatives
and slides, and 500 hours
of audio recordings.
This was the largest documentation
of life inside Afghanistan
from during the Afghan Soviet era.
In 2011 the U.S. Embassy in Kabul
provided a grant to digitize
and preserve the AMRC video,
photo, and audio archives
at the Library of Congress.
Long-term AMRC project advisors,
Nick Mills and Stephen Olsson,
are tutored at the LOC to
pass on the necessary training
to the Afghan archivists.
Digitization of materials and the
metadata descriptions in Darti,
Pashto, and English take
over three years to complete.
AMRC archive director, [inaudible],
is joined by his son, [inaudible],
now an Al Jazeera producer who
supervises the digitization
of this 30 year old video material.
The old, and often dirty, original
tapes require constant cleaning
of the video heads for a
clean digital transfer.
According to the Library of
Congress' precise specifications,
the metadata for each photo and
video event is logged in English,
Pashto, Darti, Romanized
Pashto, and Romanized Darti.
A copy of all this work will
also be available in Kabul.
The AMRC archive provides
a unique resource
for understanding Afghanistan and
one of the most important conflicts
of the last half of
the 20th century.
The preservation of this AMRC
collection will be a great asset
to scholars, journalists,
and students.
The AMRC archive will now
support historical, cultural,
and political research from
this unique society and era
for hundreds of years to come.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you, thank you very much.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: That
was -- that was wonderful.
Thank you, Nick.
Actually, it gives us a view on the
other side, which is -- which is --
which I had not seen before.
So thank you very much.
And now to represent the State
Department, Tess Delprete has served
as the Chief of the
Afghanistan Pakistan Grants
and Programs Division within the
Office of Press and Public Diplomacy
and the Bureau of South and
Central Asia and the U.S. Department
of State since 2013, an overseas
all federal assistance programming
for public diplomacy in Afghanistan
and Pakistan in this capacity.
And of course it was thanks to
the Department of State and thanks
to the grant that AMRC received
that this project was made possible.
So, Tess, would you
like to join us here?
[ Applause ]
>> Tess Delprete: Good afternoon,
Dr. Mao, Ambassador Hogland,
Ambassador Tomsen, and other
dignitaries and friends,
good afternoon and thank
you for inviting me
to this warm celebration
on this very rainy day.
It is an honor and a pleasure
for me to be here in support
of the ultimate success of
the AMRC and its achievement
and its presentation to the
Library of Congress today.
As we -- as has already
been mentioned,
in 1986 the United States
Information Agency, or USIA,
supported the creation of the
Afghan Media Resource Center,
and with it the creation of one
of Afghanistan's first
independent news agencies.
The AMRC trained journalists
to cover the Soviet occupation,
and then for years
collective reports
from all available forms of media.
In 2011 and '12, with the help of
the State Department and others,
the AMRC digitalized this record
to create what is being
presented here today.
Now a lot of my colleagues
on the panel have already spoken
quite a bit about the significance
to this, but I want to continue on
with that a little bit and mention
that this is quite special
in that it provides not
only a political narrative
of Afghanistan's past, but also
a glimpse into the human tragedy
that ensued during and
after this difficult era.
It is a record made not by
the international community,
but by the Afghan people, of
the Afghan people, and as such,
presents a local perspective
to the world a perspective
that may not have otherwise
been accessible.
In these days of global and
cross-cultural conflict and strife,
the value of contextualized
social history cannot
and should not be underestimated.
A lot has changed in
Afghanistan since the days
of the Soviet occupation, and
while conflict is still apparent,
Afghanistan has made remarkable
progress since the partnership
between our two countries began.
We heard a lot about how this --
how the Afghan Media Resource Center
was created and the significance
and why it was important,
and I appreciate the comments
from my colleagues on the panel
that explained what it was
like on the ground at that time.
But I'd like to talk
a little bit of more
about where Afghanistan is right
now and where we're hoping to go.
Besides the progress
in the security sector,
Afghanistan civil society
has made leaps and bounds,
progress in democratic development,
economic growth, infrastructure
and transportation, health,
education, and women's empowerment,
Afghanistan's communication
sector has grown exponentially.
As of 2015 Afghanistan has
a free and dynamic press
with over 75 television
stations and 200 radio stations
that together reach over
70% of Afghan households.
Household TV ownership has
risen to 58% from 37% in 2007,
and internet use has nearly doubled
in urban areas over the past year.
Print, electronic, and social media
outlets reflect a range of views,
and while risk remains, there is
increasing space for journalists
to challenge government
policies and bring attention
to human rights concerns
and to report
on instances of corruption or abuse.
Afghanistan has numerous
human rights
and civil society organizations that
bravely do the same, and are working
to advance and sustain
concrete improvements
for Afghanistan's people.
And while there is still work
to be done, the changes underway
in Afghanistan cannot be
measured by numbers alone.
Afghanistan is steadily
becoming a country
where citizens can
celebrate the achievement
of their own sports teams
on the international stage,
watch their own television
series, enjoy their own musicians,
vote for their own leaders,
and listen to their own
pundits debate public policy.
Our relationship in the years to
come will not be defined by war,
but by development assistance
and diplomatic support
to sustain the gains of the past
decade toward a sovereign, stable,
unified, and democratic Afghanistan.
The United States looks
forward to working
with the new Afghan government based
on the principles of mutual respect
and mutual accountability,
but I want to say a warm
and hearty congratulations
on your fine achievement.
Besides being a treasure trove of
historically rich and textured data,
the archive is perhaps more
importantly a shining beacon
of the undeniable resilience
of the Afghan people.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Thank you, Tess.
And now I want to move
to Greg Lukow.
Greg Lukow and and I
are the two book ends,
if you want, of this panel.
We present the library.
We hold together this project
from one side and the other.
Greg Lukow is the chief
of the National Audiovisual
Conservation Center,
headquartered at the
Library's Packard Campus
for audiovisual conservation
in Culpeper, Virginia.
He drove for two hours
to be here with us today.
And he oversees the world's largest
collection of films, television,
and radio broadcasts,
and sound recordings.
And so we are delighted that
he has agreed to include
within that large collection of
films the films that came from AMRC.
He has many achievements, which
you will find on the list you have.
And now let us hear from Greg Lukow.
[ Applause ]
>> Greg Lukow: Thank you, Mary-Jane.
Thank you very much.
Thank you all for being here.
On behalf of all of my
colleagues and the staff
of the National Audiovisual
Conservation Center, also known here
at the library as the
Motion Picture Broadcast
of Recording Sound Division, all
of my colleagues who were involved
in this project over
the last several years,
it is certainly a great pleasure
to be here with you today
to celebrate this milestone, the
completion of the digitization
of the AMRC collection, it's
conveyance to the library
as a donation, and its
preservation at the Packard Campus
of the library in Culpeper,
Virginia.
I'm here just to finish putting
in the final brushstrokes
of the picture that
we've been creating,
or perhaps a more apt metaphor is
the final pixels of the HD video
that we hope you will all
come away with in your minds
at the end of this panel.
Our role at the Packard
Campus was basically twofold,
to help Stephen his
colleagues and technical set
up for the digitization of the
files, and secondly, of course,
the preservation of the digital
collection of the AMRC collection.
We began working back in
2011 and 2012 with Stephen
to configure the digitization
workstations.
I think it was a couple of
iMacs that we put together.
That was the first time that Apple
had included the Thunderbolt data
transfer ports and
cables on their iMacs,
and that greatly facilitated
the process.
Stephen mentioned one of my
colleagues, James Snyder,
who is our technical
lead on this project.
HE sat down and identified
the digital capture station,
the analog to digital converter that
would be hooked up to these iMacs,
and the software that
goes along with it.
So he configured and he
tested the workstations
that we ultimately shipped
to Kabul for the AMRC
to digitize all this together.
That was actually an important
development for us on our side
as well, because we've used those
systems internally since then.
We then worked with the AMRC
staff and Mary-Jane's staff
to configure the metadata.
You know you're in
a library when three
of the panelists mention the word
metadata over and over again.
It's very important.
The metadata accompanying all those
digital files that we were going
to receive from the AMRC would
enable us to ingest the files
into our preservation systems,
and ultimately will
enable their discovery
by researchers coming
to the library.
Ultimately we received 44 hard
drives, each one I think was
about three terabytes each,
that were shipped to us
by Haji Daud and his staff.
We downloaded all the content
from those hard drives,
those 44 hard drives, into our
Packard Campus Data Center,
our digital archive.
Just to repeat the vital statistics,
over 1,200 hours of video,
357 hours of audio, and
94,652 photographs and slides.
Total, 125 terabytes of
digital content were added
to our Packard Campus Data Center,
joining the nearly seven petabytes
of other audiovisual content that
we store at the Packard Campus.
All of the library's audiovisual
content is stored there.
The collection is now securely
preserved at the Packard Campus.
It's backed up as any good
digital archive should be,
at a mirrored offsite second
location that the library has.
All this in addition to the copies
of the materials in the collection
that remain available in
Afghanistan as Haji Daud mentioned.
As a next step, we look forward
to collaborating with Mary-Jane
and the -- and her division to
produce the digital access copies
of the master preservation
files that we're storing
to make the entire collection
available for onsite access
by researchers and
[inaudible] reading rooms here,
like right over there, and in
our Moving Image Research Center
and our Recorded Sound Research
Center which are located
in the library's Madison Building.
For the work that is completed
and all that lies ahead,
I'd like to acknowledge
a few of my staff,
my colleagues at the Packard
Campus, as Mary-Jane did her staff.
In our Moving Image section,
Mike Michon [assumed spelling]
and especially Andrea Lee
[assumed spelling], who is the --
is the head of our process unit
within the Moving Image section.
Similarly, in our Recorded
Sound Section,
Gene Deana [assumed spelling],
the head of the section,
and Catlin Hunter [assumed
spelling],
the head of the processing unit
and the Recorded Sound Section.
Also, our Technology Office,
Stephen Neise [assumed spelling],
our chief technology
officer, and most especially,
I already mentioned James Snyder,
who had been our technical lead
on this project and collaborated
with Haji and Stephen and others
on the technical aspects.
It has been a great pleasure
to work with Haji Daud and all
of his colleagues in Kabul,
some of whom I just saw
pictured for the first time.
It was actually quite moving.
Like Mary-Jane, I saw all
that for the first time.
Haji called to my attention
a couple of his colleagues
that had been instrumental in all
of the technical aspects of this.
[inaudible], deputy of the AMRC
and the head of the archive,
who I think you saw pictured in
the video, as well as [inaudible],
production manager
and financial officer.
So my thanks to them and to Haji.
My thanks to Mary-Jane and
her team and the African
and Middle Eastern Division.
And thanks to all of
you for coming today.
We at the library are
honored to serve as the home
for the preservation
here in the United States
of this extraordinary collection,
and to serve as, we hope,
careful stewards in making these
historic images and sounds available
as living documents to future
generations, not only in Afghanistan
and in the United States,
but for the world's citizens.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Different size.
It's on. But let us thank this
panel of exceptional people
and all the people behind them
for the work that they have done.
So let us give them a hand because
they've done a fantastic job.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.